I hope the week this first week was a
good one but was exciting I hope it was
tiring I hope it was full of good
choices chances to get together with old
friends or begin growing new friends but
now that all the opening ceremonies are
finally over we get down to the work of
a university which is really schedules
labs books and yes papers and tests all
that good stuff and that first week Yale
can look very much like a hogwarts kind
of adventure with grand spaces and
ceremonies and faculty marching around
and medieval robes but now I think
you're beginning to peer behind the
curtain and see that what on the outside
can look like an upper-class British
club of some kind it's actually a place
where people work really hard it's
nonetheless exciting in fact it's more
exciting in some ways but we go from
that sort of lofty video style view of
academia down to the grind of 300 pages
of Conte to read for tomorrow and that's
that's where we get to the meat of it
and in our church to we're moving fast
our student deacons met all day
yesterday to plan for this coming
semester our first Bible study starts
tomorrow the first grad and professional
student gathering is on Wednesday and by
next week will be commissioning our new
student deacons and our Samuel sly
fellow we get down quickly to the work
of the church here as the Deacons put it
yesterday in their meeting in a
discussion about what our mission as the
church is and we're going to be working
on our mission statement this year they
said some things they said we're getting
down to the work of serving God to
reminding ourselves that God is real to
remembering what is really important in
our lives and especially that we are
here to serve God and serve others but
where do you begin some of you are in a
new place where do you start how do you
do this work in this place I thought of
Richard light who's a professor of
education at Harvard and I've heard him
speak a number of times and he talks
about what gauges or what makes for
success for high school students
transitioning to Ivy League schools he
said what are the predictors it's not
s80 scores sadly it's not even your GPA
in your old school what he said is the
number one and probably the only
predictor it's whether students go into
the new experience realizing that
they're going to have to change the way
they do things that the strategies for
success they had in high school are no
longer going to work in this new setting
and they have to go about things in a
new way those who think they can glide
along doing things the same way they
always did are the ones more likely to
fail those who realize who this is a new
place in a new world they're the ones
who succeed and I'd like to hazard a
guess that the same thing might work in
our faith that if we come to a new
experience like this one with the sense
that the strategies we used at high
school at home in youth group those
strategies are not going to carry us
through but we need to have a new
approach to faith an adult approach to
faith a new way of doing things one
that's not going to simply replicate
what we had before because we're going
to grow out of that far too soon in this
new new place and with these new ways so
how do we go about doing the work of
faith in this place in that new way I
think we can look to our scriptures
because I and the one I really liked
today is mark seven for some interesting
reasons the story of the Sarah
phoenician woman and her daughter and
the story of the deaf man who was healed
and Tom long who teaches preaching at
the candler school at Emory retells the
story but he starts with a story about
Duke Ellington the great jazz musician
and he tells the story of how long ago
40 years ago Duke Ellington teamed up
with Ray Brown
to record an album called this one's for
Blanton a live album which was rarely
unusual and long says the recording has
become legendary not only because of the
musicians and the music but also because
the microphones probably accidentally
were positioned so close to the
performers that you can actually hear
the sounds they make as they're
performing the music so you can hear a
little bit behind the scenes one
enthusiastic describes the experience
this way he says when you listen to the
recording Ray Brown is right there in
the room with you fighting with his base
you can hear his grunts you can hear the
bass moving you can hear the fretboard
buzzing you can hear Duke Ellington
moving in his chair and breathing
heavily in the rests professor long
notes that the grunts and the size and
the background of this recording remind
us that music is hard physical work the
choir makes it look easy every week you
think they're just here for fun but it
is hard work to make good music and what
long goes on to say is this passage from
mark 7 shows us that living out the
gospel living out the good news of Jesus
Christ is also hard work it's not about
niceness it's not even about
spirituality or attitude but as mark
sees it it's about work and that that
might be a new way to think about living
as a Christian in this place he compares
the noise of that recording with the
unusual language mark uses in our gospel
passage today with the healing of the
deaf man which says Jesus took him aside
put his fingers in his ears spat and
touched the man's tongue and then
looking up to heaven he heaved a sigh
and said a father be opened what long
says is that what we're seeing and
hearing in this passage the spitting the
sighing the touching is the gospel at
work the hard work of the gospel
in the healing of those who need healing
mark's gospel is cruder closer simpler
than the other three because it tries to
bring us that close to Jesus at work
your nose right in it whether that's
pleasant or unpleasant you see and you
hear what's happening you hear Jesus
eyeing you see the spit you see him
touch the man's tongue can you imagine
sticking his fingers on the man's ears
and that the gospel work is that close
it's not spiritual yeah it's spiritual
but it's so much more it's it's in your
hands and press along argues that mark
seems to portray the gospel in this way
because he doesn't believe in a sort of
dreamy highly spiritual eyes Jesus that
we sometimes think of this is a
bare-knuckles kind of Jesus in Gospel of
Mark and Jesus is involved in a
bare-knuckle struggle with human misery
and imperial power in the world Jesus is
in there and he's fighting and it's hard
work to overcome the social powers that
create human suffering the spiritual
forces that create human chains and
misery Jesus is doing everything he can
he's working a struggling to overcome
that in people's lives even when Jesus
talks to this woman of Tyre who comes
bringing her daughter to have the demon
cast out Long says that Jesus is doing
this hard work but it's a hard story
listen to it Jesus says to this unclean
Gentile woman let the children be fed
first for it is not fair to take the
children's food and throw it to the dogs
not a happy story Jesus says I came to
the children I come to the people of
Israel and the food is for them I won't
throw it to the dogs to the unclean
Gentiles in his life and his mission on
earth his mission was to the Jews and
Biblical interpreters if you read them
two remarkable dances to get around this
dude almost cruel response of Jesus but
we can't forget that Jesus was not just
fully divine but also fully human and
part of a human culture but the woman
has this graceful moment and he replied
to this exclusion she accepts it and
turns it on its head and says instead of
being insulted or angry sir even the
dogs under the table eat the children's
crumbs she doesn't challenge that Jesus
came to the Jews but she reveals that
she sees in him the power that can
overcome even the most ancient walls and
taboos that Jesus can come and feed the
people of Israel and have enough left
over to feed everyone else and heal her
daughter as long describes it he says
this Gentile woman perceives that Jesus
is pushing with all his might groaning
against the rusty bolt of demonic power
but when it comes to her daughter his
strength alone cannot break it so she
speaks a frail desperate human word and
that by God's grace becomes the word the
Word of God and when she says sir even
the dogs under the table can eat the
children's crumbs by doing so the woman
joins in faith with jesus' work she
places her hands along his and together
they push against these forces with all
their might the old rusty boat breaks
free and the healing power of Israel's
God joyously flows to the bedside of
this unclean Gentile girl
it's hard work sometimes our hard work
is needed to help Jesus is hard work how
do we do it how do we heal people and
free people how do we see that new work
that we haven't done before that we can
actually do first I think we can as he
did see human suffering and understand
it when it's in front of us if your
first few weeks of college or anything
like mine all I could think about was my
own suffering and I suffered a lot it
was tough it was a very tough transition
but one thing that helped me was
beginning to realize that there were
others around me who were having an even
tougher time and that I could be of help
to them Jesus went straight to the heart
of every person he met he cut through
all the stories we tell ourselves about
ourselves he saw the twisted demonic
forces of our own sinfulness and
selfishness of the evil empires
determination to exclude and repress of
disease and mental illness he saw them
and he saw through them and it seems the
more a person suffered the more Jesus
was drawn to them look at the Gospels
who does Jesus go to see who finds him
the people who are suffering the most
the more rejected they are the more he
wanted to bring them in not because he
was a humanitarian or perhaps even a
liberal but God because the god he was
part of God his father loved the poor
and the suffering in our passage from
James to today I don't know if you
listen to it but it convicts me when I
hear it I think it should be printed in
large letters above the altar of every
Christian Church where James writes but
if you show partiality you Christians
you commit sin and are convicted as
transgressors
we love to make the church into a club
but Jesus seems to want to make it into
an emergency room that's work James
condemns us and he says if a brother or
sister is naked and lacks daily food and
one of you says to them go in peace keep
warm and eat your fill and yet you do
not supply their needs what good are you
terrible stuff but we are provided a
Holy Spirit we are provided the presence
of God in our lives to move us beyond
even that part of our culture especially
here at Yale that says judging others is
the most important thing in life
establishing that hierarchy of who's at
the top and who's at the bottom that's
the most important thing and I want to
be at the top Holy Spirit says let's
turn that all upside down and if you're
at the bottom you're at God's top second
I think we can break down the barriers
that exclude and reject we can touch and
connect with those otherwise forgotten
or rejected as Jesus did and because
Jesus did we need to remember why that
we don't love the rejected because
they're rejected we love them because
God loves them and because God wants to
include them and finally third we can I
think to do this work not try to do the
healing ourselves but accompany those we
meet on a journey of healing we are not
miracle workers but what the gospel
makes clear is that the process of
reconciliation and healing is more
science than art that makes any sense
the sense of this hard work it's not
something that some people are skilled
at and other
people aren't this business of healing
and reconciliation is a matter of trial
and error it's hard work doing it a
thousand times as Jesus did until he
figured out a way through as he did with
this Gentile woman find how to find a
way around the barriers of human society
how to find the one person whose heart
is ready to hear it's a matter of work
doing it over and over and over again
until we find the impossible solution
and find a way to overcome the
insurmountable obstacles what would it
look like if we began to do the hard
grinding work of the gospel with
one-tenth of the energy we put into Yale
I think it would look like you and me
being willing to talk about the things
that actually separate us it's hard to
do at a place like this race or wealth
or politics or even appearance or even
where you stand on the social hierarchy
begin to seek real reconciliation in
Jesus name it would mean being honest
with ourselves and overcoming our fear
and reaching out to people out there who
need and want God in their lives right
now and only need our human touch to
feel God's reality it would mean finally
confronting the habits and compulsions
that chain us down as individuals and
work with them with God every day it
would mean looking like and looking into
an issue like the current healthcare
debacle going on in Washington and
asking how is it that the wealthiest
nation in the world is refusing health
care to its own poor you can't read
James and not think about the health
care debate I'm sorry so sitting here
listening to it that's what came to mind
I don't understand all the permutations
of the legislation but you can't tell me
that the God of James the God of Isaiah
and Amos and Hosea wouldn't rain down
fire on any nation that sees the need
and does nothing what did st. Paul say
what did the author of James say what
good is it my brothers and sisters if
you say you have faith but do not have
works can faith save you
if a brother or sister is sick and lacks
health care and one of you says to them
go to the emergency room and be well and
you do not supply their needs what good
are you so faith by itself if it has no
works is dead that's the work we need to
do I don't know how to solve the problem
but you're much smarter than I am we can
find out a way we can break through
these obstacles all this naysaying all
these people would say it's impossible
we can do it and I'm ready to get to
work this year I'm ready to set my
shoulders alongside Jesus's to push open
the chains that hold people in poverty
and immorality and mental illness and
blindness to the needs of their brothers
and sisters I'm ready to be set free I'm
ready to set others free and hope you're
ready to be set free too amen